beneath the bombs is the azov style
steel works we don't know when this
footage was filmed by the russian-backed
separatists who released it but we can
confirm the location the site of mario
paul's last stand
inside ukraine's azov regiment vow to
continue their defense
it is already the second day that the
enemy broke into the plant there are
heavy bloody battles
i am proud of my soldiers for making
inhuman efforts to contain the enemy's
onslaught i thank the whole world for
the tremendous support of the mario pole
garrison
our soldiers deserve it
trapped alongside the soldiers are
thought to be as many as 200 civilians
including children this footage released
by ukrainian forces was filmed over a
week ago and since then many have been
released but just imagine the terror of
those who remain
[Music]
above ground more than 300 civilians
were evacuated overnight and taken to
zaparizia with the help of the u.n
there are still civilians women children
to save them we have to continue the
regime of silence the ukrainian side is
ready to provide it
it takes time just to get people out of
the basements
from those hiding places underground
elsewhere in the east the battle for
territory continues this was makifkar
outside donetsk where russian-backed
separatists claimed the ukrainian
shelling of an oil depot left one dead
and two wounded
while there was yet more devastation in
kramertorsk at least 25 people injured
after an apartment building was hit
overnight one former ambassador to
russia told sky news there'll be no
chance of compromise of vladimir putin
we have to realize that he cannot win
the war
in the sense of
achieving
a settled outcome
nobody in ukraine
is going to forget what he's done and
what his forces have done
and the way they've done it
as ever the fear is what comes next as
russia gears up for its annual victory
day celebrations and a potential fresh
onsort iva bennett sky news